publican martha mcsalley has conceded
the Senate race in Arizona the one that
she thought she won the new senator from
that state will be Kyrsten Sinema
mcsalley LED on election night but his
surge of late counted votes carried
cinema to the lead in event woman's
voice senior fellow Lisa Booth has been
following this race since its earliest
stages and joins us tonight to explain
exactly what happened Lisa booth what
what exactly if you could bottom-line
what happened in the selection that
martha mcsalley and everyone watching
thought she won but now she just
conceded she's not gonna be the new
senator what happened right as you
mentioned The Associated Press has
called the race she has conceded I think
the problem largely looks like Maricopa
County this Maricopa County represents
about sixty percent of the state's
population yeah it's a Republican
leading but cinema's actually been
leading there that's where these new
votes came in from tonight that really
put her over the top which is why The
Associated Press ended up calling the
race however I would also think about
the fact that martha mcsalley might have
a chance of trying to get elected as a
senator in arizona looking at 2020
because remember senator kyle is really
a placeholder for the late senator john
mccain so she can potentially eye that
race in 2020 whoever wins that special
election in 2020 would then have to run
again in 2022 so she might be someone
you know we should throw her name in the
Hat for that ring for sure it's
interesting though I just read an
analysis and it was on 538 not a
right-wing site that said between 2000
and 2015 every single recount statewide
that changed an election result changed
it in the Democrats favor every single
one so I that doesn't prove anything but
it you got to ask the obvious question
and the obvious question in this case is
martha mcsalley is satisfied that this
process was fair well she conceded so I
you know it'll be interesting to see
what articles or what surfaces this week
if there are any articles that you know
I draw any attention to anything
nefarious that went on in any of these
counties or particularly Maricopa County
but as of right now she is conceded so I
guess not enough for her to you know to
not concede right can I just ask one
more
quick dumb question so we keep seeing
these races where they get called in all
the news organizations ours and every
other says we know who the winner is and
then we find out oh wait there all these
votes who haven't been counted right I
don't secretaries of state alert the
public and the candidates and us that
actually we're not really sure because
we have encountered all the votes has
that occurred to anybody to do that
that's a good point tucker we've also
got that going on in Georgia right now
because that race still hasn't been
called we should know more information
tomorrow tomorrow the deadline is 5:00
p.m. for counties to certify the results
and get those to the secretary of state
however Stacey Abrams has you know two
lawsuits pending one trying to move that
deadline to Wednesday and she's also
trying to get absentee ballots that have
been thrown out counted so we are we are
on that we will see you again Lisa okay
Thank You Tucker have a great night